it wouldn't be an NHL season without ups and
downs it's how you react to them manage them that
defines the ultimate outcome last year in Seattle
the Kraken in just their second season Advanced to
the second round of the Stanley Cup Playoffs
upsetting the defending champs the Colorado
Avalanche along the way accordingly expectations
for this season were high thus far the results
have not been good job on puts it in his in Las
Vegas for last year's Stanley Cup champions this
season's start was as good as last year's finish
out back the golden knights didn't taste defeat
until the eighth game and won 12 of their first
13 but since then it's been a bit of an unexpected
[Music] struggle up ahead for the League's two
most recent expansion teams is the NHL's signature
event the Winter Classic outdoors in Seattle on
January 1st the Winter Classic always takes you
back to your roots it's an awesome event to look
forward to to have the opportunity to do it it's
a dream come true this outdoor game big arena
at home we're so happy we're doing it here in
Seattle playing in front of 60,000 people little
different magnitude right but before they ring in
the New Year there's still three weeks of games
to play an opportunity to turn the lows into
highs on the road to the NHL
Winter Classic presented by
Enterprise can run a little cross drop on
Entry despite the festive time of the year
for the Seattle Kraken this hasn't been a
season for for any sort of Celebration wins
have been hard to come by but hope is on the
horizon after missing the previous 20 games
a top forward Andre burkovski has returned just
in time for a season long six-game homeand we're
nearly a third into the season and really we're
still trying to find our our ultimate 60-minute
identity statistically once you get to this time
of year and Beyond if you're chasing a game you
don't win very often like I don't care how well
you play in the second and third if you're down
by one or two team or true structures good to yeah
we got to find that purpose a little bit earlier
that's been our issue the last couple games you
can't manufacture it we got to we got to find it
in this league if you want to put yourself into
playoff contention you have to really limit the
negative runs right now uh we're in a stretch
where where we're working towards finding uh
that successful identity take a look at the uh
schedule that we have coming up all at home but
it's a it is like okay let's go let's go now we
got to beat what on the schedule look like good
teams we got to do it at home and we got to do it
now we've been playing some good hockey but not
good enough I think we got to find a way to pay
attention to every little details of the game cuz
uh those really matter uh especially when you're
struggling we got a home stretch right now that
we got to focus on and uh try to accumulate as
many win as we can obviously a tough road trip
we going to send a couple guys down we'll call
up rker go go wi play his first game hopefully
that gives us a little bit of a spark try and
get the ship red here at home today at practice
all eyes are on 21-year-old defenseman rker Evans
Seattle's second ever draft pick who's a day away
from playing in his first NHL game might just be
ready to roll and you know that okay okay okay
how' you uh how you feel it all comfortable yeah
right it was good felt like pretty normal good
you look good you look smooth you look look
confident so thank you get get what you need
today get off here and uh enjoy the night and uh
be ready to roll tomorrow okay sweet thank you B
7:30 game tomorrow night normal morning skate
10:30 morning skate it's it for the day good
[Music] work in the middle of a stretch
in which the Vegas golden knights are
playing 10 of 13 games on the road
the players are looking forward to
a yearly tradition bringing their dads
on a road trip this one to St Louis and
Dallas Pro goes through about 700 sticks
a year well he says he has goes through
400 I yeah like he he uses like a new stick
every period it's crazy oh see I like that
I could use
that since no one ever wants to disappoint their
parents the annual father's trip started with a
6 to3 win over the blues so today's practice
before the second game in Dallas is rather
light-hearted all around went through a little
of a l there had we had a pretty tough November
uh we're on the road for quite some time so uh
it's nice to get home and spend some time with
your families and I think that's been uh uh
giving us a little bit of jolt as well I got
scared I know I saw you Mary he never stops eh
i' been with this team now a year and a half so
last year when the Dad's dinner came it was
more the middle the year I was still getting
to know people and obviously them gray down
here I told them I I admire that the way our
team interacts with one another the respect and
kindness they show for one another listen they
chirp each other all the time there's all kinds
of that good-natured fun but at the end of the
day they're good people not only them to the each
other but to the coaches the trainers everybody uh
real classy guys and I think that's a credit to
[Applause] Parenting IM dad's watching all these
dads have the same outlook on life they've all
gone through a lot of work getting kids to the
NHL so they all have something in common which
is great we we love being with each other it's
beautiful sometimes it's hard to tell who
enjoys the more but at this dinner it's
clear both groups love being around
each other in fact since the knights
started doing this with their Dads the
team has played nine games and hasn't
lost a single one who raised this guy to the
dads that are able to make it for those that
aren't able to make it and those that are no
longer with us uh cheers and uh have a great
trip Che
rker Evans first game will of course be a night
to remember but it's also a milestone for the
team the first time in the Krakens three-year
history that a player will make his NHL debut
on home ice first game in the National how you
feeling pretty excited uh obviously you're a
little nervous but I'm pretty excited I remember
being nervous um my first game but excited to
it'll be good it'll be fun any family coming
in night ranks uh yeah parents got in last
night I'm sure they're excited eh yeah they're
pumped the Kraken return home for their first
lengthy home stand of the season game one of
six tonight against the New Jersey Devils the
Kraken are ready for some rein enforcements
as the return of Andre burkovski and the much
anticipated National Hockey League debut of
defenseman rker Evans stands moments away
let's go boys let's go let's go put a little
water in yeah seriously let go rer Evans on
the ice right now taking his rookie lap a lot of
folks real happy to see him in a kraken sweater
so you talk about an emotional evening for him
by many accounts we're getting a first glance
at a big piece of the Kraken future it hasn't
really sunk in and I've believed in them for so
long but yeah it's just emotional and so proud
of him the tears came when he came over for his
rookie lap I didn't think I was going to cry
but I did it was amazing rker Evans first game
oh okay man from the drop with a puck
pace and execution executing with the
puck all the way through right from
the drop of the puck Don tells you
starting here all right here we
go up front we got buet on the
back for the first time since Thanksgiving
Eve the climate pledge Arena faithful being
introduced to tonight's starting lineup
the Kraken embarking on a six game home
stand sitting just Five Points back of that
second and final wildcard spot let's be on
it early here R it early yeah good job
having lost their five previous games
tonight the Kraken hope their fresh face
on defense will bring a new and different
result stay on it one stay on it and from his
first NHL shift Evans is impressive I need to
get my uh camera out for his first ship oh
we here we go going it's going right yes
dude I could barf the ne I'm shaking Brian
duban comes in to help out Evans steals the
Pu Seattle clears it away go go go go
go rer R up The Far Side for K I feel
like they know where each other [Applause]
are see that's a great track rer Evans off
to the wing in his NHL debut shooting that
one turned aside by Schmid well we've seen
a couple of shifts by rer Evans so far
and I like what I've seen he's playing
simple hockey out there stay on the B stay
on the fortune good play that was a good
shift [Applause] [Music] [Applause] yes great
sticks up and down the ring oh nice shot keep
shooting those M nearly went airb over the top
of Airaid two up left eer lcks one across back
out in front they score we talk so much about
momentum in this league you don't want to give
the opposing team that momentum keep that puck
for the kids first game Little Bit Stronger here
baby Johny gord's line is out there to start
the second for the most part the Kraken have
played well tonight but a tieing goal Still
Remains elusive right back right back esap
escap around over the near side wiber takes it
out in [Applause] front there's some energy in
this building now for the Kraken well we
talk about four check pressure and cring
turnovers and that time there was Brooky
in the corner that did exactly that here we
go go away below the goal line worked out in front
for nemes they scor shimone nemes gives the Devils
the lead again once again down a goal Seattle
gets more bad news when Andre burkovski has to
leave the ice Andre Bovi down the tunnel for
Seattle the effort was there and unfortunately
they're down a goal going in the locker room
last clip we're going to see is is the go we
score we're for checking we're on it great job by
winning to check it back come on one shot let's
go as the final period Begins the Krakens seem to
be playing with Coach Dave haxo much wanted sense
of purpose the back turning up the pressure here
he D do on it do on it y yep yep y y baby wber
in front turned aside byid and a diving save
by Aira Schmid two onone shorthanded McAn and
gour McAn right Circle his shot off the posted
on the play Far bro yeah extra attacker on for
C can I set up uh caner here cuz like it's
the Lefty against right get the side okay
yeah yeah despite outshooting the Devils 2 to
one Seattle still can't break through and play
the final minutes at a frantic Pace luck comes
out here's Vince dun steps into a shot misses
wi it gamoto on the side of the cage and the
Devils hold on a goal line stand they pushed
they pushed they pushed right until the very end
Seattle just not able to to get over that hump
what are your thoughts on rker Evans in his
NHL debut he ended the night plus one yeah 17
minutes of shifts two shots on goal two hits
I think a solid night for 39 the development
of our youth is extremely important as we all
saw it tonight Riker's ready for this league
one day does not make a career but uh you know
he played very well tonight and deservedly so
he's worked hard to to gain that opportunity I
was a little nervous at first but a lot of the
guys help me settle in and play my game and I
was trying to soak it all in but it went by so
fast in a game where burkovski returned only to
again leave injured the loss is the Krakens sixth
in a row not what they had hoped for on a night
of new beginnings on the road to the NHL Winter
Classic presented by Enterprise official
partner of the NHL Enterprise for lives in
drive just a season ago Bruce Cassidy and
his Vegas golden knights overcame a slew of
goendale Cup last year with Logan Thompson one
of the injured it was Aiden Hill who stepped
up this year with Hill out since the 1st of
December it's the reverse uh the golden kns
are in a good place gold tending been split
about equally Hills out now for a bit but um
both guys have played well given us a chance
to win every night so um scoring is the one
area that our team could be a little more
consistent in but we're getting it we need
it it's our third time we played Dallas this
year so I expect it'll be probably a oneg goal
game either way and if we do the right things
we be able to get get on the right side of that
since he came to Las Vegas last year just about
everything has gone right for Cassidy well almost
everything oh boy got Patty on the job I knew
it in Dallas on a Saturday afternoon the Golden
Knights visit the Stars to cap the father's trip
the major test for the golden knights tonight
this is their 13th game in 26 days 10 of those
13 have been on the road they've got through
this stretch and state in first place they've
set themselves up for major season success wheel
right doesn't work to the we know this team right
on the four check so make sure we're talking
to one another every option's in play for us
all right we'll try to help you with that but
talk to one another on the ice all right other
than that let's go get to our game win your races
win your battles there's their start Nick wah huy
petro and LT and that'ss here let's go in the
first and today the scene shifts to Texas for
an afternoon affair against the Dallas team
the golden knights have already knocked off
twice this season it's the stars and the golden
knights underway and American Airline centering
they're going to be over here in a hurry hey just
be ready for pressure from their deep oh boy nice
try after an 11 game Span in which they won just
three times the golden knights have played much
better of late and tonight in front of their
dads the good times continue ston the other
way to Mar to ston and a sa with a blocker Chand
Stevenson to try to end that lengthy Dr that Steve
good spot there out High sack white clown with
aist shot rebound score Stevenson buries that
one if anyone needed it it is number 20
Chandler Stevenson that's a big goal for
him to do it with his dad here oh my Paul
oh boy good stick good stick wide in the
zone carier out high as white cloud shot score
it's goals and backto back games for Zack White
[Music] Cloud no matter the
score with Vegas expectations
are always high and sloppy play by anyone isn't
tolerated oh d hey man a off on the right
wing a shot save rebound score Dallas gets
on the board and the golden ice pay the price
for the turnover I'm just telling you you got
to mismanage the pucks two shifts just not there
play behind them come on it's my bad play behind
him how just turned it over I know it was I'm
just saying read the ice let's get it back yeah
we'll get it back sorry for that come on let's get
focused here Michael you're line got five second
eel your line Mel on the move with barers and
stone out high and his shot block Second Chance
score Mark Stone buried his own rebound and
the captain has made it 3 to one in the first
as the period comes to a close and the Golden
Heights take a 3-1 lead to the locker room you
got anything no just leave me alone Keegan we had
lots of success on the rush that when the plays
are there we make them scored two goals that
way just make sure you're making them in the
zone right not through the middle of the ice with
four and five guys back all right let's go win the
spirit man behind you behind you behind you attck
the middle nice boys there Jack come on Jack come
on guys hard hard stolen with a steel trying
to feed w w TOs and and scores Nick W buries
it his first and 13 and it's 41 Vegas short feet
of barf White Cloud out top hon LS inter up and
a save on jerk right before the horn to end the
period on last year's run to the cup the knights
had many contributors and the final 20 provides
an opportunity for some of them to regain their
confidence s and C with a little bit of room to
the red line gain the Dallas Zone driving into
the slot with a chance he missed it second B score
pavor and the golden knights have blown it open in
Dallas it's 5 to one I missed that on purpose
missed it on purpose bro Dallas just unable to
get anything going so far in the game hey sorry
for yelling at you earlier sorry for yelling at
you earlier I blame you for play for Meck loose
out High MN to Conor con with a back and he scores
another one that needed it it finally Billy the
celebration continue up in the suep and this one
never end doubt 61 over Dallas after a 6-3 win
in St Louis last [Applause] [Music] [Applause]
night what a hell of a week have all the dads
here know it's a tough one for me but uh I
thank all you for including me everything
and making me feel like I'm a part of it
myself goes a long way but this is a special
game number 200 [Applause] fori might have
to start bringing these guys on every trip
huhy yes sir seriously that's a great trip
boys uh playing as a team winning as a team
having some fun with the old guys let's keep
going for the defending champs the winds keep on
coming now heading home with even more points to
be had for the Kraken it's the opposite a losing
streak that continues with no end although there
have been special moments along the way a week
of contrasting emotions on the road to the NHL
Winter Classic presented by Enterprise official
partner of the NHL Enterprise for lives in
Drive